Recebi essa pergunta. Usar semente de
linhaça trituram todo dia contribui no
consumo de ômega-3 ou é irrisório? Bem,
pessoal, essa pergunta sobre linhaça é
daquelas que aparece toda semana. Sabe
quando você tá ali triturando suas
sementinhas de linhaça todo santo dia
achando que tá arrasando no ômega-3?
Pois é, vamos conversar sobre isso com
franqueza,
porque tem muita gente por aí
confundindo as coisas. Aliança, gente, é
uma semente maravilhosa, isso ninguém
discute. Ela é riquíssima em ala, que é
o ácido alfa linolênico com tipo de
ômega3 vegetal. Uma colher de sopa de
linhaça tem cerca de 2,3 g de ala.
Parece bastante, não é? E realmente é
uma quantidade considerável, mas aí que
mora o pulo do gato. O nosso corpo sabe
o que ele faz? Ele precisa converter
esse ala linolênico, né, em EPA e DHA,
que são as formas ativas do ômega3,
aquelas que realmente fazem diferença
pra saúde cardiovascular, pro cérebro,
pra memória, para controlar a
inflamação. É como se o Ala fosse a
matéria-pra bruta e o EPA e o DHA fossem
um produto final refinado. Aí vem a
notícia que pode ser meio frustrante
para alguns. Essa conversão é
extremamente ineficiente. Estamos
falando de uma taxa conversão de apenas
5% pra IPA, quando muito. E pro DHA,
rapaz, nenhum 1h% conseguimos converter.
É tipo você colocar R$ 100 numa
maquininha de câmbio e sair com R$ 5 do
outro lado.
Complicado, né? Agora, calma lá. Não tô
dizendo para você jogar sua linhaça no
lixo. Pelo contrário, mesmo com essa
conversão baixinha, o consumo de água de
linhaça não é irrisório. Ele contribui
sim. pro seu pul de ômega-3, se você
consome duas colheres de sopa por dia,
está adicionando cerca de 4 a 5 g de ala
o linolênico, que pode resultar em uns
200 a 250 de EPA. Não é muito, mas
também não é nada. O problema é quando a
pessoa acha que só a linhaça resolve. É
como querer encher uma piscina com copo
de água. Vai encher, vai, mas demora
para caramba e pode não ser suficiente
pro que você precisa. A medicina
funcional hoje recomenda pelo menos 250
a 500 mg de EPDH por dia combinados para
manutenção da saúde. Para condições
específicas como inflamação crônica ou
problemas cardiovasculares, precisamos
de doses bem maiores, chegando a 2 ou 3
g por dia. Tem outro detalhe
importantíssimo que muita gente não
sabe. A conversão de ala para EPA e DHA
depende de vários fatores. Sabe aquele
óleo de soja, milho, girassol que a
maioria usa para cozinhar? Pois é, eles
são ricos em ômega-6 e quando você
consome muito ômega-6, ele compete com
ômega-3 pelas mesmas enzimas de
conversão. É como se fosse um
congestionamento numa estrada de mão
única. Quanto mais carros de ômega-6,
menos espaço para ômega-3 passar.
Mulheres em dar fértil tem uma vantagem
aqui. O estrogênium parece melhorar um
pouquinho essa conversão, chegando a uns
8 a 12% pra EPA, mas mesmo assim
continua sendo baixo. E os homens
esquece, a conversão ainda pior.
Diabéticos então tem uma dificuldade
extra nesse processo de conversão. Agora
eu vou te dar a real sobre como otimizar
isso tudo. Primeiro, continue sim com a
sua linhaça triturada na hora. E tem que
ser triturada na hora mesmo, viu? Porque
o linolênico ala oxida rapidinho quando
exposto ao ar. Mas não pare por aí.
Adicione outras fontes de EPA e DG
direto. Sardinha, salmão selvagem,
cavala duas a três vezes por semana já
fazem uma diferença brutal. E olha que
interessante, estudos recentes em 2024
mostram que a combinação de fontes
vegetais e animais de ômega-3 pode ter
um efeito cinético. O ala da linhaça tem
suas próprias propriedades
antiinflamatórias. independente da
conversão. Então, não é uma questão de
escolher um ou outro, é somar forças.
Para quem é vegetariano ou vegano, a
situação fica mais desafiadora, mas não
impossível. Hoje temos suplementos de
águas marinhas que fornecem DH
diretamente, sem precisar passar pro
peixe. Uma cápsula dessas pode ter de
200 a 500 mg de DHA. É uma opção bacana
para complementar a linhaça. Deixa te
dar uma dica de ouro aqui. Se você quer
mesmo melhorar a conversão do ala da sua
linhaça, além de reduzir ômega6,
capricha no magnésio, zinc com vitamina
B de bola 3 e B6. Esses nutrientes são
com fatores essenciais para as enzimas
que fazem conversão. É como colocar óleo
no motor do carro, sabe? facilita todo o
processo. E tem mais uma coisa que
descobrimos recentemente. O horário que
você consome a linhaça pode fazer
diferença. Estudos sugerem que consumir
pela manhã, em jejum ou com café da
manhã pode melhorar a absorção,
utilização do ala. Então, aquela sua
vitamina matinal com linhaça tá no
caminho certo. Resumindo a ópera, usar
linhaça todos os dias contribui sim pro
seu consumo de ômega-3. Não é irrisório,
mas também não é suficiente como única
fonte. É como se fosse a base da
pirâmide, você precisa construir em cima
outras fontes, seja através de peixes
gordurosos, seja através de
experimentação adequada. Na minha
prática clínica, o que eu vejo funcionar
melhor é essa abordagem integrativa.
Mantém a linhaça pelo alfa linolênico e
pelas fibras maravilhosas que ela tem.
Adiciona peixe duas vezes por semana
pelo menos e complementa com o
suplemento de qualidade quando
necessário. E sempre, sempre reduza o
consumo de óleos vegetais refinados
ricos em ômega-6. Então, continua
triturando sua alinhaço todo dia. Sim,
com certeza. Mas entenda que ela é parte
da solução, mas não é a solução
completa. É como montar um
quebra-cabeça. Aliança é uma peça
importante, mas você precisa das outras
peças para formar a imagem completa da
saúde. E no fim das contas, essa visão
integrativa que a medicina funcional
propõe, usar o melhor de cada mundo para
alcançar a saúde ótima, não apenas a
ausência de doença. S.